he's the quarterback for the washington
football team he's alex smith kind
enough to join us
alex i'll get to you in a moment how's
your wife doing
she's she's doing good i think she uh
obviously put her through some stress on
on sunday but uh
she was pumped she was just as excited
as as me i think uh
especially going out there and doing it
and getting through it and you know get
that first hit out of the way
um but yeah i think she definitely was
uh was feeling it
on sunday because i'm watching and
you know she can't do anything about it
your kids are there you know they
probably say dad's out on the field mom
is probably going
oh my god we've been through so much
she's holding her head like she doesn't
know how to react there have you seen
the video of
uh i saw the good clip and i think it
kind of sums it up
i felt like my wife's certainly there
and you know feeling feeling it
you could you could see the stress on
her face and and you know obviously
concern and
my daughter's oblivious my four-year-old
daughter is dancing next to her
in the stadium you know my boys are i
think my boys were a little more in tune
but they still had you know i don't
think kind of
a great idea and just kind of taking it
in the dad's back out there
um but yeah it was it was fun funny to
see that i was i was really happy they
got to be there you know we hadn't had
fans the first couple home games so
i was i was pumped that the families got
to come out and they got to be there
with me because my wife has
been through so much the last couple
years with me and uh so
so cool for her to be there and uh to
share with me
i also wonder if it helped that you
didn't have a week to prepare for this
moment
like it was just hey alex go out on the
field
yeah in a lot of ways you're right like
rip the band-aid off it was like as soon
as the hit happened
on kyle i knew it was it was a good one
and uh yeah i went over and grabbed my
helmet i was like let's go let's it's
time to
time to go you know warm up a little bit
get a few frozen get a couple snaps and
like
no time to think um in that sense yeah
it was kind of nice just this let's
go no build up uh straight to it so
yeah and in a lot of ways thankful that
for that you know for me it's also it's
been it's been hard with no off season
no preseason
um you know take away the take away
the injury for me it's obviously being
out of football for two years as well
and so for me taking advantage of the
reps
getting back in um what it's like so it
was nice to get thrust out there
especially into a two minute drill
where it's kind of just just go play and
react and for me a lot of that i think
those instincts knowing
that that all there just kind of i felt
like uh hadn't left so it was nice to
get back in there and get in the mix
but i know this may sound strange what
felt more like football
the past that you complete or aaron
donald
trying to take your head off like i
always as a quarterback and this has
been my entire career you know like
coaches
i think talk to you about you know as
far as getting into a rhythm and for me
it's
it's kind of one of the other get it get
a good completion or get hit
you know and i think both as a as a qb
kind of help you get into the game into
the flow of things so
nice for me to kind of knock both those
out pretty early
did aaron donald say anything to you
like when he's trying to tackle you i
mean everybody
knows what you've been doing obviously
the one time when i didn't know it was
him that jumped on my back and then i
knew it at some point
i felt like it was in slow motion like i
felt like i had a body on my back
you know i'm standing there and
certainly uh you know to
to to know that i'm good to go uh with
that and obviously feeling strong
out there so that was nice uh aaron's
aaron's obviously a heck of a player but
uh you know obviously a really good
person as well i've been around him
a little bit off-season so a ton of
respect for him and and loved
loved it uh obviously he brings it and
so it was nice out there to uh
certainly get thrown into the fire a
little bit are you competing for the
starting job
you know for me yeah yeah i mean i go
out there and compete every single day
that's the deal
you know camp was was a little different
you know i started on pub
and and you know obviously a little bit
had to go prove it uh that i can do this
and so kind of
starting behind the ball we got a couple
young young quarterbacks that obviously
you know getting the majority of the
reps so for me trying to take advantage
of my reps taking advantage of
my opportunities out there and make the
most of them and yeah certainly this
week to kind of make
to get bumped up to the two and and know
that i was one play away and then i knew
the reality of that
as much as anybody so for me being ready
my number's called i'm ready to roll and
and uh
this leaves about making the most your
opportunities and uh
so for me excited about whenever this
next one comes he's alex smith
he is the uh quarterback for the
washington football team last time you
were on the show
you got traded to washington two hours
later
yeah did you know when you were in
minnesota that day you were going to be
traded
when you went on the show am i under
oath
yes you are
[Laughter]
you know there that was kind of honestly
it was it was uh
it was ironic that that you know that
day kind of doing some of the media
there around super bowl that day
uh that was kind of the day when a lot
of that was actually going on so in and
out a lot of that i was kind of getting
updated
um in between on my phone and and uh
with with conversations so
that was the day it was happening so
yeah certainly i knew i knew things were
in the mix
a little weird to be doing uh obviously
media in the middle of all that
have you watched the documentary on your
comeback your surgeries
i did yeah i i watched it this off
season when i heard it was you know
it's uh not only you know a little bit
scary obviously to put all that out
there
um to let the cameras in and try to be
real that was my goal
from the get-go when i decided to do it
was just i wanted to be honest and real
and
not hide anything and so yeah you never
know how that's sometimes going to come
out
um so yeah i was i felt like it's like
everybody else wanted to see
uh anyone see it i couldn't get through
it
couldn't do it no i i've had i've had
six surgeries on my knee
but nothing compared to that and i i
just i i tried and i
at some point i went you could lose your
leg and you're
you're allowing a documentary and i
don't know how close
you could have died but i know that you
were close to maybe losing a portion of
your leg
at any point do you say to your wife or
does your wife say no this is
like let's get the cameras out of here
yeah i think the thankful thing yeah i
mean
certainly when i had sepsis and and
things were my life was kind of in
danger
at that point i see it was just
you know doctors just trying to save my
life and then from there save my leg
and i think once once i had elected to
to go with limp salvage and and
obviously the the numerous surgeries
that
that was gonna take um and the unknown
that that's when the documentary became
you know a reality
once we headed down that road and so for
me was a lot of thought but certainly
the uniqueness of the situation
for me also the uniqueness that uh a lot
of the
all the technology even the surgeries
the limb salvage surgery that i had a
lot of that was all perfected
um because of the service men and women
especially these last
you know 20 25 years in the middle east
and there had been so many
limb injuries um you know
from the wars in the middle east and so
for me to kind of benefit from the
technology
uh that our service men and women uh you
know had gone through
i i think was part of it for me that it
really kind of made it worthwhile i was
the first obviously i think athlete to
kind of go through this
um this was kind of uncharted territory
as far as the road back and
and there were no guarantees that i was
even going to get beyond maybe even just
trying to walk
and obviously that was scary um and
i'm thankful to be obviously where i am
today and
for so many things so yeah that was kind
of the thought process for me that that
um i i wanted it i was i was benefiting
from so many people before me and i felt
like i owed it to anybody coming after
me to kind of
uh document it and help you know hope
progress
can you win comeback player of the year
after five weeks alex
i don't care
for me the the feeling the feeling
uh being out there the the emotions the
the being on that edge that's why i came
back and
certainly in the middle of it right now
and just taking it day by day so
i wondered about this it's not fair to
put you in the position but you know
when dak goes down with that kind of
injury and
and this is a fraternity with
quarterbacks do you reach out
yeah guys great thing you know you know
for me especially with dak i feel like
we have a ton in common because he
played for
for you know my same coaches all through
college you know a bunch of
you know dan mullen coached him in
college my good friend brian johnson
was his quarterback coach all through
college so uh that's a guy i keep up
with a lot certainly in the division as
well so i have a ton of respect for i
love his game
i love him as a human being everything
he's about so
i i just gotten home uh from the game
you know celebrating you know with you
know taking it on with my wife and
kids and we had to we had the cowboy
game on so i watched it happen live
um yeah and you know
i feel like i've become a little bit of
an expert you know especially on
the lower leg and so yeah knew looked
like his ankle immediately and
um you know for me
yeah thinking about him a lot i i
thought a lot about i've checked up on
him through our mutual friends and and
seeing how he's doing i thought a lot
about shooting the text
part of me also didn't want to scare the
hell out of him by shooting him a test
i feel like i kind of want to let him
i'll let the infection risk
kind of get out of the way and hopefully
reach out here soon
well i don't know what the next chapter
is but you gave us a hell of a one this
past weekend and uh
you know like i said i've been through
so many surgeries
and you're going out there to play
football and that's completely different
so
my admiration for you as as a man i mean
that's
that's impressive stuff and and
certainly your wife to be able to be
there because i know how important that
is
have that support because without that
you know maybe you're not you're not
here you're not in this moment right now
yeah that's right yeah thank you dan
appreciate it thank you alex
uh that's alex smith the uh quarterback
for the washington football team